le capital public en france à ceci
d'extraordinaire
qu'on soit riche et célèbre c'est ça
qu'on soit défavorisé et inconnus on est
soigné de la main vide à ce moment
arrive avec un carte vitale c'est vrai
que par est à 4 vital que tu te sois un
émir où que tu sois un sdf et ce à tous
ceux qui m'ont soigné je les ai observés
de très près c'est une aventure un
voyage un ce extraordinaire même si je
pensais ne pas revenir de ce voyage j'ai
vu des gens magnifiques
j'ai vu des infirmières des aides
soignantes de nuit qu'on dévie
incroyable mais juste michel humez
regagner leur vie qui habite à à 2h30 de
paris
on a beau le savoir mais quand est
soignée que tu es quelqu'un qui a un peu
pignon sur rue mais on était persuadé
que moi j'étais persuadé que j'étais
inoxydable à terminator que j'ai que
j'étais aussi destructives si j'étais
persuadé de sa propre tête et avec moi
ils racontent tu vois deux femmes
charmantes qui ont peu dormi qui ont
amené leurs gosses à l'école quand des
problèmes avec leurs maris de chômage
des problèmes économiques pendant
laquelle prend pas pensant à cette année
épouvantable sur l'économie que tout
était à l'arrêt et qui arrive avec le
sourire une fille remonte le moral
allez monsieur rata vous allez vous en
sortir vous pour frais de la télé à
l'élément dimanche se reprend à est
étiqueté rien tu es un pantin étaient
disloqués tasse en temps quand tu te
regarde dans la glace mais j'ai mis deux
mois avant d'enlever la buée sur la
glace après la douche que vous avez la
tête que jamais je suis ressemblera aux
bleus mais saint martial
c'est sûr c'était et s'est dit mais
c'est pas possible j'ai jamais je vais
refaire surface dans l'année plus de
jambes j'avais plus de plus de plus de
muscle nulle part il ya un moment très
fort dans le livre c'est une
conversation que tu avec l'équipe
médicale
tu dis attendez si ça se passe mal je le
dis en présence du docteur hagège vous
me débrancher
comment ça je vous des branches oui
débrancher mois hors de question que je
puisse me réveiller avec des handicaps
avec une aphasie un tremblement je ne
pourrai plus jamais pratiquer mon métier
alors ce n'est plus la peine pour me
débrancher ce n'est pas légal vous
débranchez plutôt mourir que me
réveiller son pouvoir exercer mon métier
ça c'est un assassin harrison ford en
lui oui parce que tous ceux qui ont été
opérés qui me regarde et je leur
souhaite vraiment de garder le moral
c'est là que ça se passe aussi
c'est le protocole il n'y a pas
d'opération sans risque et une opération
comme la mienne a été gigantesque il
fallait convention genval qu'on fasse un
triple pontage comme des bouche la jambe
qu'on surveille de début d'avc et on
m'avait dit on saura si vous avez des
séquelles uniquement au réveil on opère
un choeur par le cerveau donc on sera au
réveil est donc le protocole c'est ça le
l'anesthésique gergorin dit voilà si ça
se passe mal on prévient qui si ça veut
dire quoi
non mais vous savez nous allons prendre
un gros risque avec cette opération il y
avait 50 50
donc qui on prévient mais si vous prenez
ma femme d'abord mais vous débranchez
mais quand ça vous dit vous débranchez
j'ai dit ça devant albert à jet ski le
patron du service de cardiologie de
l'hôpital européen georges-pompidou
cassis et lui pour la première fois en
général c'est un tête à tête entendent
anesthésie c'est le malade personnes
assistent à ça j'ai dit vous débranchez
si vous venez pour débrancher parce que
parce que je vois là je peux pas de hors
jeu pouvait pas refaire mon métier c'est
pour ça que j'en suis très reconnaissant
à la gouvernance de france tel est
maudit on t'attend partir on t'attend
anglais des gentils on m'attend demain
mais si on revient dix minutes je vais
revenir ont déjà entendu parler de
prothèses puisqu'on devait me couper la
jambe au dessous du genou droit
prothèse je dis bon vin j'irai le voir
syrie avec une prothèse voilà et puis on
fait du tennis et qu'une prothèse à ces
jeux et je ferai du vélo sur une jambe
comme un mec qui m'a doublé un jour dans
le ventoux car un bras une jambe